[CHOIR SINGING]
PENNA ROSE: Choral music can
be a transcendent experience.
Everybody comes bringing
a different gift.
Some have great pitch, some
have a great personality.
Some have just the ability to
sight read specks off a wall.
So you put all of
these people together,
and all of those
talents make the group
bigger than the individuals are.
My name is Penna Rose.
I'm the director
of Chapel Music,
and this is my 25th
year at the University.
My goal with this choir is
to infect these students
with the love of choral music.
ELIZA DAVIS: One
of the things that
has been so great about being
president of Chapel Choir
is being able to
work with Penna,
and have her sort of guide me.
I think she was sort of the
first adult at Princeton
that I really felt
comfortable with
and I really felt sort of
had my back in anything.
I feel so lucky to have had her.
I think Princeton can
be really hard at times,
and Penna has always been
sort of that constant presence
and guide for me
here, which has been --
I'm extremely grateful for that.
PENNA ROSE: So please,
do everything you can.
You're right here.
All you've got to do is look
up and there's the stick
right in your face, right?
They're just
imagining it, and it's
happening right on the beat.
They're just amazing,
amazing, amazing.
So please be equally amazing.
How about that?
All right, good.
ERIC FUNG: I think
that Penna really
does emphasize making the
music mean something to you
and connecting with
the text and the --
and the -- the music.
She is definitely a mentor
figure, not just to me, but
to everyone else in the
choir and to whomever
wants to have that
relationship with her.
She will definitely
be open to that.
PENNA ROSE: So you
turned your thesis in.
ELIZA DAVIS: Yes, I
turned my thesis in.
PENNA ROSE: Good, OK,
tell me all about it.
I
00:01:53,660 --> 00:01:54,910
What was it about?
ELIZA DAVIS: So it was
about -- so I was writing about
the Millennium Development
Goodoals, and how --
PENNA ROSE: Princeton
is competitive,
and I think can
be difficult. So I
want them to have
a safe space where
everybody is treated the same.
This space becomes their home.
When the kids graduate
and they talk about it,
after they've graduated,
they talk about
the community of the choir and
how important that is to them.
[CHOIR SINGING]
JENNIFER BORGHI: Penna
taught me probably
the most essential
lesson about making music
that I have ever
received and which
I see embodied by only the
best and rarest musicians
that I've encountered since --
since I left here.
Penna said to me one
day, never ever, ever,
put yourself before the music.
That sums up the way
Penna makes music.
That sums up music in
this chapel and the reason
why I keep coming back.
Penna is one of very few people
I know who conveys that over
and over again.
What you are singing, what
you are saying is important.
ERIC FUNG: From
Opening Exercises,
to yesterday's
Baccalaureate, she
has filled our
undergraduate lives
with heavenly sounds
and angelic music.
And she has not only
served as a mentor,
but has also been a great friend
to many in the audience today.
We would like to thank her and
extend her an honorary class
membership.
And we're surely happy
to have her in the ranks.
Welcome to the great
Class of 2017, Penna.
[APPLAUSE]
PENNA ROSE: I tell the students
often, um, in this space,
there has been music going on.
There have been a lot of words
also spoken in this space.
But there's been a lot of music.
And the music from those
former times is in the stones.
And so this is your
opportunity to put your music
in those stones, so that
in future generations,
that sound is going
to reverberate
with what they are doing.
And it's very important.
That is part of your
legacy at Princeton
is to put your beautiful
sound in these stones.
I've never found anything else
that feeds me like music does.
I tried to do other
things a couple of times,
and I was miserably unhappy.
So I said, all right, I give up.
I will just do this, because
it brings me such joy.
[SINGING, MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERING]